bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo les temps forts de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire en 45 minutes
avec michaël szames f
bonjour tiare bonjour michael laissait
une semaine sous le signe de
l'environnement avec le coup d'envoi de
la coop 21 les grands de ce monde ont
retrouvé françois hollande au bourget
près de paris au chevet du climat à la
france veut faire de ce rendez vous une
réussite dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique n'est pas facile
de satisfaire les intérêts de tous les
critiques de plus en plus vives contre
les pats dur georges bernard cazeneuve
défend son dispositif d'exception
annonce la fermeture de quatre mosquées
les défenseurs des libertés
individuelles et certains parlementaires
dénoncent quelques dérives et puis
c'était donc que les derniers jours de
campagne pour les élections régionales
les candidats ont jeté leurs dernières
forces dans la bataille le front
national est en tête des intentions de
vote
le national au premier tour front
républicain ou pas contre le fn les
parties se divise notre invité cette
semaine pour commenter toute cette
actualité david rachline bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur du front national
maire de fréjus sénateur du var vous
allez commenter toute cette actualité et
on va commencer bien évidemment par la
caf et l environnement l'environnement
et lundi 150 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui se réunissent à paris
pour le coup d'envoi de la coop
c'est donc parti pour quinze jours de
débat sur le climat les grands de ce
monde ont posé aux côtés de françois
hollande pour la photo de famille et
puis les discours se sont succédé à la
tribune xhaka promettant des mesures
pour éviter un réchauffement de la
planète à + 2 degrés il faut trouver un
accord contraignant a martelé françois
hollande écoutez je ne pose pas la lutte
contre le terrorisme à la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
ce sont deux grands défis mondiaux que
nous devons relever parce que nous
devons laisser à nos enfants
davantage qu'un monde libéré de la
terreur nous leur devons une planète
préservée des catastrophes
une planète viable est ce que pour vous
david rachline 9 françois hollande a
pris un risque politique en organisant
maintenant cette coop 21 s'il n'y a pas
d'accord contraignant
je crois qu'il est dans son rôle de
président de la république et que c'est
une initiative qui est plutôt positive à
l'évidence le véritable problème c'est
qu'un certain nombre de grands débats
urgents ne sont pas abordées dans le
cadre de cette grande réunion des chefs
d'état le pense le patriotisme
économique les circuits courts le fait
que aujourd'hui à cause du mondialisme à
cause de l'idéologie prônée par les
grands de ce monde ont produit à des
milliers de kilomètres de là où l'on
consommé on retraite ces mêmes produits
encore plus loin la paix mais libre
échange ce que j'appelle le livre est
une chose à montréal il est absolument
qu'ils sont de véritables dangers pour
notre pays pour son économie pour notre
société mais aussi pour l'écologie non
seulement françaises n'ont vraiment rien
mais aussi pour l'écologie mondiale et
ce sont des sujets qui ne sont pas
abordés je le regrette parce que je
pense que ça apporterait vraiment aux
débats aux demandeurs fait un nouveau
modèle économique c'est ça absolument il
faut le réformer de fond en comble notre
modèle c'est clairement le patriotisme
économique c'est le fait de produire au
plus près c'est de favoriser les
circuits courts pour faire écouter dans
un certain nombre de nos cantines on
mange des produits qui sont fabriqués à
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres ça n'a
aucun sens il faut évidemment faire en
sorte de travailler
de faire travailler d'abord nos
agriculteurs par exemple dans ce domaine
là de faire travailler nos entreprises
les favoriser dans le cadre des marchés
publics
c'est vrai au niveau des régions mais ça
devrait être le cas aussi au niveau de
l'état et des grandes entreprises telles
que la sncf qui attribue des marchés
quelquefois des entreprises qui ne sont
pas des entreprises françaises
je le regrette ces nouveaux ce discours
au front national vous êtes converti au
vert mais pas du tout écouter vous avez
la gentillesse de me poser la question
donc je vous y répondre mais je n'aurais
pu vous répondre exactement la même
chose il ya plusieurs années déjà
c'est vrai alors par exemple quand on va
dans le nord-pas-de-calais comme marine
le pen se remet à proposer ce fameux
projet canal seine-nord qu'elle avait
refusé en 2010 et aujourd'hui a dit
c'est très bien c'est parfait c'est
exactement ce qu'il fallait faire moi je
suis pas un spécialiste ou poser
question qui vous a pas échappé que
j'étais sénateur varois j'ai décompressé
pas spécialiste de ces questions mais je
sais que j'obtienne un vrai changement
marine le pen s'adapte à la situation
locale
il y à des évolutions permanentes dans
ces régions il faut tenir compte
évidemment vous vous adaptez évidemment
que nous adaptons nous sommes un
mouvement politique qui vit avec son
temps qu'ils s'adaptent et nos
propositions doivent coller avec le réel
et je crois que même nous sommes les
seuls à nous adapter véritablement à ses
grandes évolutions de notre temps elle
va changer un petit peu de sujet mardi
le premier ministre reçoit les
parlementaires
et au menu de cette réunion qu'il veut
hebdomadaire un point régulier sur
l'état d'urgence qui est de plus en plus
critiqués on entend très souvent ces
derniers temps nous prémunissent a tenu
à rassurer les parlementaires voient
tout cela avec jennifer se mais le
gouvernement s'y était engagé les
parlementaires ont été reçus tout à
l'heure pour faire le point
perquisitions arrestations modification
de la constitution et surtout état
d'urgence
manuel valls envisageait ce matin une
prolongation au-delà du 26 février
du côté du groupe socialiste les
sénateurs approuvent dans les jours qui
viennent et j'ai affirmé au nom de mon
groupe que si pour les besoins de
l'enquêté pour les besoins de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
il fallait que l'état d'urgence soit
éventuellement prolongé en février sous
réserve de ces précisions le groupe
socialiste et républicain du sénat
soutiendraient le gouvernement dans la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
on les républicains s'étaient à
d'urgence décrétée le 13 novembre est
elle nécessaire mais ne doit pas déroger
aux principes de l'état de droit la
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est la
priorité absolue mais elle n'autorise
pas toutes les méthodes il faut donc que
même dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
le droit soit respecté sous le contrôle
du juge que ce soit le conseil d'état où
le juge judiciaire
le sénat sera en première ligne une
mission de suivi de l'état d'urgence
piloté par l'ancien garde des sceaux
michel mercier va débuter ses travaux le
9 décembre elle auditionnera notamment
ce jour là le procureur de paris
françois molins parmi les mesures
prévues par l'état d'urgence la sinne il
ya donc l'assignation résident certains
militants écologistes en ont fait les
frais ce qui a provoqué la colère de
noël mamère bernard cazeneuve du coût a
défendu son arsenal devant la
représentation nationale écoutez je ne
veux pas je ne peux pas accepter que les
forces de sécurité aujourd'hui puissent
prendre en charge dans l'espace public
des casseurs je ne l'accepterai jamais
et tous ceux qui l'acceptent sur ses
bancs dont monsieur mamère qui s'agitent
sont dans l'irresponsabilité totale et
je tiens à le dire très clairement ici
pour ce qui concerne les militants
écologistes y en a eu aucun d'assigner
ceux qui ont été assignés ce sont des
individus violents
qu'il continue à jouer les hypocrites
qu'il continue son discours schizophrène
mais moi je n'ai pas à répondre à ce
monsieur
alors avant d'évoquer réunion de
matignon est ce que et qu'est-ce que
vous que vous avez vous que cet échange
entre bernard cazeneuve et noël manas
bernard cazeneuve a eu raison de réponse
qu'il a écouté le gouvernement a fait le
choix comme il l'avait fait après les
événements du mois de janvier de montrer
ses muscles et laissez nous faire croire
à une prise de conscience véritable de
la situation tant mieux c'est un certain
nombre de mesures sont prises c'est
éminemment positif le problème c'est que
il faudrait qu'on passe de la parole aux
actes
parce que la réalité dans ce pays c'est
qu'il ya à peu près 80 mosquées
salafistes
on le sait et rien ne se passe pour le
moment on attend toujours
on attend toujours les actes de ce
gouvernement qui c'est vrai communique
beaucoup fait beaucoup de déclarations
fait beaucoup de déclarations
tonitruantes et il reçoit les
parlementaires à l'exception des
parlementaires du front national
d'ailleurs à l'exception des
parlementaires de médias ce n'est pas
que je sache
mais ça n'est pas une surprise pour nous
nous savons que le gouvernement à la
démocratie à deux vitesses mais groupe
qui était aussi les représentants c'est
ça oui c'est ça bon avec la
proportionnelle que nous rétablirons le
problème sera réglé
mais toujours est il que voilà on attend
maintenant des actes parce qu'encore une
fois la communication c'est bien mais la
parole c'est bien mais les actes c'est
mieux
je vous le dis on les attend toujours
pour le moment est ce que vous
souhaiteriez que l'état d'urgence soit
prolongée mais probablement ce sera sera
ce sera nécessaire sans doute mais si on
vous entend bien c'est nécessaire mais
pas formé mais ça n'est pas tellement le
problème le problème c'est le problème
de fond et le problème de fond c'est de
se poser la question des frontières et
de la sortie de l'espace schengen le
problème c'est de se poser la question
générale de l'immigration la question
générale du laxisme pénale que nous
subissons depuis des années qui fait que
quand on est condamné à moins d'un an de
prison aujourd'hui on ne les fait pas
réellement etc
ce sont toutes ces problématiques là qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas abordées et qui
mettent en danger les français et c'est
ça qui est très inquiétant c'est que les
français aujourd'hui ne sont
plus en sécurité y compris avec les
mesures malheureusement de ce
gouvernement qui ne sont pas suffisantes
donc pour vous l'état d'urgence c'est
pas suffisant même si on instaurait
jusqu'à 6 mais c'est positif mais ça
n'est pas suffisant car il faut aussi je
vous le dis renvoyer chez eux les imams
les imams qui prêchent la haine contre
les valeurs de la république contre la
france
toutes ces mosquées salafistes prise en
main par les extrémistes à une action
unie verts dénoncent action il ya je
crois que quatre mosquées qui ont été
fermés quatre ou cinq
il y en a 80 qui sont répertoriés qu'est
ce qu'on attend pour mettre dehors ou
pour déchoir de leur nationalité les
fichiers est ce dont on sait qu'ils ont
de la sympathie des organismes radical
sachant les déchoir de la nationalité
et puis les expulser ensuite dans leur
pays est resté sur notre territoire ce
n'est pas que symbolique
quand vous expulser des gens qui sont
des terroristes pouteau potentiel alors
vous sécurisez quand même un peu le
territoire aujourd'hui ça n'est pas fait
comment se fait-il qu'ils ont supprimé
des dizaines de milliers de postes dans
la police dans la gendarmerie baisser
les moyens des services de renseignement
aussi bien d'ailleurs sur le
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy que sous
françois hollande on nous dit
aujourd'hui il va y avoir quelques 10
quelques centaines de postes
supplémentaires créés moi j'appelle à ce
qu'on revienne aux effectifs antérieurs
à la prise de pouvoir par nicolas
sarkozy c'est à dire au moins 13 mois
s'est de plus et donc ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait aller bien au delà des budgets
alloués aujourd'hui oui absolument
absolument mais vous inquiétez pas on
peut faire bien des écoles avec les
difficiles avec des oui alors ça qu'on
veut faire bien des économies par
ailleurs et je crois qu'il ya des
priorités absolues quand il s'agit de
sécurité des français ils attendent les
français qu'on assure leur sécurité
c'est le rôle de l'état
il faut qu'il la sent prise de laisser
filer les déficits mais je vous le dis
je pense que ça n'est pas une question
qui doit être prioritaire on ne négocie
pas avec la sécurité des français
et croyez-moi par ailleurs il y a
beaucoup d'économies à faire justement
sur programme économique il ya eu pas
mal de réactions cette semaine aurait
autour du programme économique du front
national
la presse régionale les milieux
culturels les syndicats sont montés au
front contre le front national et
notamment pierre gattaz
c'est le patron des patrons voient cela
avec aurélia romaine à quelques jours du
premier tour des régionales
pierre gattaz met le feu aux poudres
interview dans la presse et enfonce le
clou devant les journalistes mon
problème c'est pas le front national mon
problème c'est la politique économique
du front national qui me rappelle la
politique l'extrême gauche et qui me
rappelle celle du programme commun de la
gauche de 1981 qui nous a conduits dans
le mur
dans son viseur le programme national du
fn la sortie de l'euro le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans ou encore la hausse du
smic défié sur son programme économique
la présidente du fn lui répond par sa
meilleure arme l'attak
s'il est si sûr de lui qui viennent
débattre avec moi il ne le veut pas
voilà il ne le veut pas parce qu'il n'a
rien à dire parce que les arguments
qu'il utilise sont les arguments
totalement caricaturaux qui peuvent être
démontée en l'espace de cinq minutes
il se fonde d'ailleurs sur des travaux
qui sont faits par l'ump soit disant des
fondations mais en réalité c'est l'ump
qui est derrière ou par le parti
socialiste
bah c'est bien ump/ps medef même combat
parfait un amalgame entre les
républicains et le medef que son
président tente de contourner la
retraite à 60 ans l'augmentation du smig
cetera sans faire attention la baiser
charge la compétitivité et
l'attractivité ça aura un impact sur
l'entreprise et la compétitivité de
l'entreprise sait tous qu'une ce dont je
veux qu'ils me kim qui me gêne
aujourd'hui je n'ai su gré sur le parti
sur le programme politique je vais
suivre un programme économique et pas de
politique mais cette attaque du medef
fait suite à celle de certains journaux
locaux du nord qui se sont positionnés
contre une possible victoire aux
régionales de marine le pen c'est très
clair c'est tous contre vous c'est le
retour de la victimisation du front
national habitudes
j'essaye de préserver les places et les
postes qui sont les leurs et qu'ils
craignent de perdre à l'occasion de ces
élections régionales quoi ça veut dire
qu'ils arrivent au pouvoir voulait
renvoyer m envoie pas mais c'est les
français qui vont les renvoyer pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont échoué parce que la
politique qu'il mène depuis des
décennies désormais est catastrophique
on entend des leçons d'économie de la
part de monsieur gattaz et la part des
responsables du parti socialiste il ya
jamais eu autant de chômeurs dans notre
pays que qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on
parle jamais il y à une situation aussi
délétère en matière économique et vous
dites dans notre pays que la photo les
abîmes du parti socialiste la faute de
la dhr
tout cas oui la faute des mesures et des
grandes orientations qui ont été prises
par nos élites depuis des dizaines
d'années qui a produit cette situation
et nous et nous et les français le
savent bien nous allons nous efforcer au
moins de changer le cap économique de
faire en sorte qu'on intègre le
patriotisme économique qu'on fasse en
sorte de privilégier est d'aider les
petites et les moyennes entreprises
certes peut-être pas les multinationales
comme le souhaiterait monsieur gattaz
mais au moins les petites et les
moyennes entreprises qui créent de
l'emploi dans le pays et qui sont
absolument écrasée de charge aujourd'hui
c'est ces gens là que nous souhaitons
aider ils le savent bien d'ailleurs
mais vous accepté d'entendre certaines
critiques ils croient ni dans mon coeur
non mais tout le monde a tort sauve ou
non on entend on en entend ce qu'ils
disent simplement ce que je constate
c'est que leur politique amené la france
à la ruine a mené à une situation encore
une fois en termes d'emploi qui est
absolument catastrophique nous expliquer
que nous serions ce qui allons aggraver
la situation je crois que c'est une
plaisanterie peuvent regarder yano
barrère et un sondage monsieur rachline
ifop pour la provence et sud radio nous
dans votre région région paca 56 % des
interrogés faire un impact négatif sur
l'économie si vous arrivez au pouvoir
avec marion maréchal-le pen
65% des investisseurs étrangers vous
fait peur non mais vous allez je crois
pas du tout que nous fassions peur
d'abord au niveau des élections
régionales
et si nous prenions devient un certain
nombre de régions restons dans le cadre
des compétences pourquoi il nous parle
des sujets nationaux alors qu'on est en
plein dans une élection régionale sanaa
d'abord là on parle de l'intérieur
économique ensuite ensuite les
entrepreneurs sont peut-être 51 ou 52 %
à croire ce que racontent 56 ça veut
dire qu'il y en a une bonne partie qui
ne croient pas 7
cette charge un petit peu tonitruant de
la part de nos adversaires
je crois qu'ils paniquent voilà la
réalité je crois qu'il panique qui sont
en train de caricaturer totalement notre
programme économique car en réalité rien
de ce qu'ils disent n'est conforme à la
réalité de ce que nous souhaitons nous
souhaitons précisément baisser les
charges pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises
essayer de soutenir
l'emploi et l'économie dans notre pays
je voulais pas être des acteurs
économiques concentré notamment des
petites pattes mais évidemment je me
suis rendu d'ailleurs moi même un
certain nombre de salons pour discuter
avec ses chefs d'entreprise qui nous
disent les petits chefs d'entreprise qui
nous disent la concurrence déloyale avec
des entreprises chinoises ou men et
autres a été créée par l'ump est sa a
été créée par ce modèle économique et il
faut en sortir parce qu'il faut aider
par priorité les entreprises de notre
pays qui aujourd'hui sont abandonnés
sont soumises à une concurrence qui
n'est pas supportable
david rachline je disais dit tous contre
vous écoutez ce que disait le premier
ministre annuel valls et bâtiments ce
qui ne montera pas il reculera si chacun
fait son devoir de vacances où les
français vont bosser et chacun devra
prendre ses responsabilités à gauche
comme à droite pour empêcher le fonds
national de gagner une région ont dû
répondre quoi premier ministre mais je
lui réponds que ce sont les français qui
doivent décider et que monsieur valls
s'il n'est pas d'accord avec ce principe
clair qui est celui de la république et
de la démocratie il faut qu'il change de
régime et qu'ils en fassent en tout cas
la proposition manifestement ils sont
pas aussi démocrates qui veulent bien le
dire en refusant que par exemple 20% ou
25% des français peut-être 30 demain
soir présenté à l'assemblée nationale où
puissent gérer des collectivités
territoriales comme nous le faisons je
crois que monsieur valls doit s'habituer
à la démocratie doit s'habituer à l'idée
qu'il n'y ait pas que des gens qui
pensent comme lui je pense que ce serait
une bonne chose maintenant c'est aux
français de se déterminer et les
français pour terminer en ont assez de
la magouille électorale entre l'ump
jean-christophe colle à la réalité
magouille électorale à magouilles
électorales la magouille électorale oui
mais parce que c'est la réalité la
magouille électorale c'est ce qui fait
que le choix des français est contournée
par des accords des arrangements mais
pourquoi ne se ne se présente il pas
ensemble dès le premier tour
les choses seraient extrêmement clair là
vous conseille par exemple la région
paca où les examens des socialistes
pourrait se désister
par exemple parce qu il est bien évident
que si m6 trône et l'autel est pas là si
monsieur estrosi pas très loin si
monsieur estrosi était élu avec les voix
de la gauche
il ferait une politique de centre gauche
tout le monde le sait très bien et les
habitants de la paca n'en veulent pas de
cette politique alors que monsieur
estrosi assume ses responsabilités se
présente dès le premier tour avec
monsieur castaner et les français les
habitants de notre région
jugeront il en est même pour les autres
régions marine le pen estime que le fn
est en position d'en porter entre quatre
à cinq régions parle même de 6 est-ce
que c'est ambitieux je crois que c'est
une attente de la part des français que
de voir un véritable changement que de
voir que la hausse des impôts n'est pas
une fatalité que l'insécurité endémique
telle que nous la connaissons n'est pas
une fatalité que l'absence de
développement économique
l'absence d'aménagement du territoire de
formation parce que nous nous pâtissons
que cela concrètement dans nos régions y
compris les élus d'ailleurs avec la
présence de projets ambitieux à cause de
la catastrophe socialiste qui agiraient
nous gérons nos régions depuis des
années je crois qu'ils ont soif d'une
alternative que nous proposons ils ont
envie de nous laisser notre chance c'est
une très bonne chose à mon avis devrait
vous faire réagir aux propos de jean
christophe cambadélis qui a dit c'est le
retour de vichy
à l'époque c'était contrôlé juste
maintenant c'est contre les musulmans
enfin écoutez ça n'est pas sérieux ça
n'est pas du niveau on sait que monsieur
cambadélis est en difficulté que sont
partis les son parti va prendre une
claque phénoménal aux élections ne sera
pas la première vous me direz une blague
phénoménal aux élections régionales plus
personne ne croit à ce genre d'argument
pitoyable les gens savent bien que nous
sommes des élus républicains attachés à
défendre nos territoires nous le voyons
bien dans les communes que nous gérons
d'ailleurs que nous exerçons avec
honneur les responsabilités que lui qui
nous a été confiée et je crois que c'est
un véritable dérapage scandaleux que de
faire de telles accusations très
rapidement il ya une donnée importante
pour ces régionales c'est l'abstention
est ce que vous en avez peur est ce que
vous pensez que ça peut vous servir ou
pas du tout oui moi je craint
l'abstention parce que je suis favorable
à ce que les français soient les plus
nombreux possibles à se prononcer et
c'est toujours c'est toujours
regrettable quand on est républicain que
de savoir que trop de français sont
dégoûtés par la politique pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux d'ailleurs on
peut les comprendre
parce que ce balancier ump ps ump ps qui
ne change rien qui ne fait que continuer
dans une politique qui même notre pays à
la ruine
on peut qu aurait alors à nous de
montrer à nous de montrer qu'il ya une
alternative possible et à nous de leur
faire croire qu'il est possible
de faire un véritable changement dans ce
pays enfin en attendant je vous propose
de revenir à l'actualité parlementaire
puisque mardi toujours l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi de
modernisation du système de santé un
texte porté par marisol touraine qui a
suscité et qui suscite depuis des mois à
la polémique et l'opposition d'une
majorité de médecins notamment la mesure
qui instaure la généralisation du tiers
payant
david rachline cette mesure est elle
pour vous une mesure de justice sociale
la santé pour tous et bien je crois que
c'est une mesure dangereuse les
professionnels de santé se sont
mobilisés je crois que le gouvernement
ne tient absolument pas compte des
réalités de notre pays des réalités des
professionnels qui les alertent pourtant
sur ce dossier là mais aussi sur
beaucoup d'autres on s'en prend tantôt
médecin tantôt au notaire tantôt aux uns
et aux autres
je crois que c'est un véritable danger
parce que ce sont des secteurs
professionnels qui ont besoin de l'aide
du gouvernement qui ont besoin de l'aide
des parlementaires ou aujourd'hui on va
les affaiblir je crois que c'est
extrêmement dangereux
je vous propose de passer au mercredi on
parlait de l'état d'urgence n'a encore
parlé un tout petit peu l'état d'urgence
est sous surveillance au parlement le
sénat comme l'assemblée nationale vont
le surveiller de très près les deux
commissions des lois ont annoncé
qu'elles allaient mettre parce qu'on
appelle une veille parlementaire les
détails avec thibault le floch
c'était une condition sinequanone pour
les parlementaires pouvoir contrôler en
temps réel l'action du gouvernement sous
l'état d'urgence
pour cela jean jacques urvoas propose
que la commission des lois dispose
pendant trois mois des mêmes pouvoirs
qu'une commission denquête toute
personne dont nous jugerons l'audition
utile sera tenue de déférer à la
convocation de la commission des lois
tous les renseignements de nature à
faciliter notre mission devront nous
être fournie
nous serons ainsi habilité à nous faire
communiquer tous les documents de
service et les parlementaires vont avoir
du travail
au vu des chiffres dévoilés par bernard
cazeneuve après quasiment trois semaines
d'application de l'état d'urgence nous
avons procédé à 2235 perquisition
depuis le début de l'état d'urgence ces
perquisitions ont permis deux cent
soixante trois interpellations qui ont
conduit à 232 garde à vue ce que nous
voulons savoir c'est si toutes ces
perquisitions sont vraiment justifié il
faut qu'on puisse avoir des remontées
précise on a ouvert un site pour cela
pour contrôler pour vérifier la
justification de ces packs cision le
suivi de l'enquète des parlementaires
est à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'assemblée nationale avant la
publication d'un rapport parlementaire
dans trois mois on sait bien kilomètres
sous surveillance de la part des
parlementaires c'est de travail c'est le
travail c'est le travail des
parlementaires que de surveiller l'état
d'urgence qu'est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils à des dérives pas de
la part de l'état pas de la part du
gouvernement et qu'il y aura de la part
des services de police
j'ai vu en revanche de vraies dérives de
la part d'un certain nombre de
mouvements d'extrême gauche qui n'ont
pas hésité à saccager un certain nombre
d'endroits et compris de souvenirs dans
les rues de paris au moment de la coop
21 avec des manifestations absolument
scandaleuse que l'état n'a pas été
capable de juguler ce qui en dit long
sur
l'inquiétante situation que nous vivons
sous surveillance les omis manifestement
manifestement ce n'est pas suffisant et
moi je crois qu'il faut dissoudre ces
mouvements extrémistes qui mettent à feu
et à sang un certain nombre de nos
communes
il faudrait qu'il est un grand joueur
allait dissoudre ou témoin état
d'urgence ou non il faut dissoudre ce
genre d'organisations extrémistes qui
met en péril la sécurité des français
comme on l'a vu encore ces jours ci
c'est clair est ce que vous pensez qu'il
est possible d'instaurer ce contrôle en
temps réel que réclament les
parlementaires quand il s'agit de
mesures exceptionnelles comme l'état
d'urgence voulu aussi le contrôle est
compatible vous et moi je crois que ce
contrôle est utile je crois que ce
contrôle est utile que les partenaires
que les parlementaires qui sont les
représentants des français doivent
savoir ce qu'il se passe exactement ça
ne veut pas dire que l'état doit leur
demander l'autorisation systématiquement
faut qu'ils aient un équilibre qui se
crée mais le contrôle est utile
maintenant encore une fois ce n'est pas
vraiment le sujet est le véritable sujet
c'est que qu'attend le gouvernement pour
aller plus loin plus vite plus fort pour
rétablir la sécurité dans notre pays
pour l'instant on en est loin puisque je
vous rappelle que rien n'a été fait je
vous le disais tout à l'heure ni sur
l'immigration les trois millions de
migrants annoncé par l'union européenne
par la commission européenne
vont-ils venir sur le territoire comme
c'était prévu puisque le gouvernement
n'a pas réagi sur ce sujet voilà on
attend des réponses maintenant précise
on les attend toujours par rapport aux
groupes aux personnes très régaliens
radicaliser qui font l'objet de fiches s
vous proposez quoi de plus la déchéance
de la nationalité pour les binationaux
c'est la gauche qui le propose va être
fait donc ça n'est pas fait on attend
toujours a passé sa part m attendais non
mais y'a pas du tout besoin et alors là
je vous le dis clairement il n'y a pas
de besoin du tout d'une réforme
contribuerait pour le faire ça fait
maintenant quinze jours trois semaines
qu'on attend qu'ils le fassent pourquoi
ne le font-ils paris aujourd'hui c'est
la question que je pose comment se
fait-il qu'on soit encore obligé
d'attendre avant de déchoir de leur
nationalité ces fichiers avant de sortir
de schengen et de rétablir véritablement
des avances de fermer les mots c'est ça
la pensée que ça elles sont au nombre de
80 sur notre territoire et qui sont
encore ouverts que ça passait loin ce
qu'on attend c'est sam accusé l'ong
les gens se radicalise aussi c'est le
cédant des dans des lieux qui sont
autres que les mosquées parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont très surveillées
c'est sûrement vous le savez bien et
cancer d'ailleurs il faut que c'est
ailleurs que rendre leurs moyens aux
services de renseignement dans notre de
notre pays pour qu'ils puissent faire un
travail efficace c'est l'essentiel le
renseignement dans ces domaines là il
faut donc que le gouvernement alloue des
moyens supplémentaires à nos services de
renseignement et puis une fois qu'on a
des gens écoutent et j'étais sur un
plateau la dernière fois où une
responsable du parti socialiste me
disais oui mais davantage avec les
fichiers c'est qu'au moins on peut les
surveiller mais enfin entre temps
parfois ils font des attentats et donc
il faut prendre un certain nombre de
mesures pour les mettre ensemble et pas
souci c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne fait
pas non parce que quand leurs liens avec
l'islamisme radical est avérée il faut
les mettre hors d'état de nuire en
prison ou les exploits nice ils sont
étrangers en amont bien sûr avant qu'il
fasse des attentats si possible oui je
vous propose de quitter un petit peu
l'état d'urgence pour quelques instants
en tout cas parler de tout autre chose
les enfants de chômeurs peuvent ils être
privés de cantine c'est la question que
se pose en tout cas certaines
municipalités qui ne réserve pas de
restauration scolaire aux élèves dont
les parents travaillent
une proposition de loi pour lutter
contre cette pratique a été rejeté par
le sénat les explications de matériaux à
la cantine pour tous ce n'est pas encore
pour tout de suite
en tout cas au sénat ce matin la
commission a donné un avis défavorable
au texte visant à garantir l'accès de
tous les enfants dans les cantines
certaines communes refusent les enfants
de chômeurs faute de place ou par souci
d'économie la priorité est donc donnée
aux enfants des parents qui travaillent
un fonctionnement discriminatoire que
dénonce david assouline
il faut absolument la république une
indivisible sur ces principes
fondamentaux le principe fondamental de
l'égalité d'accès là c'est pas le c'est
pas un enfant c'est pas une question de
mérite c'est pas une question de
comportement
c'est une question on le refuse pour des
raisons financières
et les enfants selon qu'ils aient des
parents qu'ils aient les moyens ou pas
vont être jetés
on ne dispose d'aucun chiffre officiel
sur les communes concernées
la dernière enquête date de 2011 du
journal le monde
37 communes restreignant l'accès à la
restauration collective sur des critères
parentaux y étaient recensés mais pour
la droite il est inutile de légiférer
sur ce sujet il ya des communes qui
n'ont pas la possibilité financière de
le faire et ça serait de donner un
mauvais signal aux communes de les
obliger de faire cela je crois que c'est
un faux problème c'est un faux débat
c'est encore le débat politique de dire
certains partis politiques ont du coeur
d'eau dans nos pages crois que c'est pas
ça affreux simple c'est une prise de
position réaliste aujourd'hui ce texte
est inutile
il est d'une grande générosité au départ
mais il est dangereux
finalement parce que les mères en a un
peu ras le bol une proposition de loi
qui a été adoptée par l'assemblée au
mois de mars
le texte sera discuté en décembre au
sénat vers la chine cette partie
catalyst lieu chez vous à fréjus nous
est le maire écoutez le véritable
problème aujourd'hui c'est que les
collectivités territoriales sont dans de
traverse une période particulièrement
difficile parce que l'état a passé son
temps ces dernières années aussi bien
d'ailleurs ce niveau-là sarkozix ou
françois hollande à faire des économies
sur le dos des collectivités
territoriales si bien qu'elles sont en
grande difficulté et que s'explique on
ne met pas les enfants la cantine et que
parfois quand il n'y a plus de place on
soit obligé de refuser un certain temps
sur des critères mais il est bien
évident que si on avait la place
nécessaire en accepterait l'ensemble des
élèves en tout cas moi si la place est
disponible alors je ne fais pas de
distinction entre les uns et les autres
je répète ma question c'est pratique
mais athènes du genre mais en revanche
en revanche mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on ne peut pas passer son temps
à exiger toujours davantage que la part
des mairies de la part des collectivités
territoriales sont leurs données les
finances la proposition de monsieur
assouline pourquoi pas accueillons tout
le monde au sein de cantine mais qu'il
nous donne les moyens pour le faire
aujourd'hui ils passent leur temps la
ville de fréjus c'est un million cinq de
dotation en moins chaque année
est ce que vous vous rendez compte des
difficultés dans la économique et
financière budgétaire dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec les rythmes
scolaires qui ont coûté quatre cent
mille euros pour une commune de 50000
habitants ça fait déjà 2 millions
d'euros de la seule responsabilité
l'état s'il nous donne les moyens pour
prêt pour parfaire notre politique
j'allais dire et à ce moment là l air
les républicains qui disent pas une
question de coeur ou pas mais l'ours
d'argent chez les questions budgétaires
évidemment aussi l'ensemble des
municipalités pouvait accueillir
l'ensemble des élèves
on serait les premiers avis mais chez
vous c'est lorsque je crois qu'il n'y a
pas de problématique avec cela dans la
ville
en tout cas aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
accueille tous ceux qui le souhaitent
en revanche je comprends qu'il y ait des
petites communes dans lesquelles n'y ait
pas de salle suffisamment grande ou deux
possibilités budgétaires d'en accueillir
davantage
alors que l'état n c'est que les
collectivités et à ce moment là on en
reparlera aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le
cas il faut arrêter d'en demander
toujours davantage aux collectivités
alors on revient aux questions
parlementaires parce que jeudi il est
question de révision de la constitution
on en parlait lien instant le projet de
révision constitutionnelle sera donc
présenté en conseil des ministres 23
décembre la veille du réveillon de noël
il sera auparavant examiné par le
conseil d'état ce texte doit consolider
l'état d'urgence il prévoit également la
déchéance de nationalité
stéphanie des pierres à l'heure actuelle
l'état d'urgence est régi par une loi de
avec les révisions constitutionnelles
ses modalités d'instauration ne change
pas ce sera toujours par décret
présidentiel
selon le projet du gouvernement la
constitution ne donne pas de durée
maximale pour l'état d'urgence c'est
toujours la loi qui en fixera la durée
en revanche les mesures administratives
qui en découlent ne pourront pas
s'exercer au delà de six mois
à droite comme à gauche les députés se
prépare un long combat contre le
terrorisme
à l'évidence là
menace terroriste islamiste qui est très
élevé aujourd'hui elle sera encore très
élevé le 26 février au moment où l'état
d'urgence expirera est-ce qu'il faut
prolonger l'état d'urgence un débat
qu'on devra voir dans les semaines à
venir
à l'évidence on aura encore besoin de
moyens opérationnels juridique pour les
préfets pour les policiers parmi les
autres mesures figurant dans le projet
de révision constitutionnelle la
déchéance de nationalité
elle existe déjà pour les binationaux
qui ont acquis la nationalité française
elle sera étendue aux binationaux qui
sont nés français
d'ores et déjà cette idée fait bondir
une partie de la gauche c'est une
première entaille au droit du sol
franchement je vous le dis je ne pensais
pas que la gauche serait capable de
faire ça c'est non seulement
insupportable mais c'est indigne de ce
que la gauche a porté pendant tant
d'années
le débat sera pas de savoir si on la
retire aux terroristes ou pas le débat
sera de savoir si quand on a un
binational est vraiment un français
c'est ce que l'extrême droite nous sort
une depuis les années on disant que mon
donc sinon on met le doigt dans cet
engrenage
s'arrêtera pas le gouvernement devrait
présenter sa réforme constitutionnelle
en conseil des ministres le 23 décembre
et au parlement en janvier pour être
adopté elle doit être votée par les
trois cinquièmes des parlementaires
david rachid interrogé sur la révision
constitutionnelle je vous pose en jim
jarraf et bonjour notre partenaire
bonjour je vais vous poser quelques
questions dans un restaurent 4 voilà
alors d'abord sur cette révision
constitutionnelle donc projet de loi
présenté en conseil des ministres avant
la fin de l'année ensuite au mois de
janvier ce que vous êtes prêts à aller
au congrès a voté cette révision
constitutionnelle l'agent don attendons
de savoir ce qu'il y aura concrètement
dans cette réforme allait mais encore
une fois il m'apparaît que c'est
beaucoup de communication on discute
beaucoup on parle beaucoup
ce qui fait réagir d'ailleurs aussi la
gauche on voit que certains ne sont même
pas prêt à assurer la sécurité des
français y compris dans les amis actuels
du gouvernement dans ce qu'ils le
soutiennent on l'a vu à l'instant la
réalité c'est qu'il ya un certain nombre
de mesures
je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure qu'il
faudrait prendre immédiatement on ne
prend pas on attend de faire encore
davantage de communication
tout ça est bien gentil mais ça ne
sécurise pas notre pays jover l'instant
sur la question de la binationalité
d'ailleurs on entendait noël mamère ou
un autre député qui parlait de la fin du
droit du sol
oui ça serait la fin du droit du sol
mais d'abord je crois pas que ce soit la
fin du droit du sol moi je suis partisan
de la fin du droit du sol ça serait déjà
les partisans d'une réforme de la
nationalité je pense que la nationalité
s'hérite ou se mérite
c'est extrêmement simple une personne
qui ne pose aucune difficulté à notre
pays doit pouvoir acquérir bien sûr la
nationalité française
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle
est donné massivement à des gens qui
dans bien des cas ne la mérite pas c'est
le véritable problème les binationaux
sont français à part entière mais oui
tant que la binationalité
existent ils
disposent ils ont la nationalité
française mois l'artiste députés qu'on a
entendu nous en gobant dernier pas comme
français nous mais n'importe quoi on
considère l'ensemble des français comme
d'un véritable français ça me fait aucun
doute en revanche il est vrai que nous
proposerons de faire en sorte qu'ils
choisissent à un moment donné parce que
nous sommes contre la binationalité par
principe nous considère pas ce que c'est
dangereux et évidemment le nous leur
poserons la question de savoir laquelle
des deux nationalités
ils veulent choisir je pense que c'est
utile à la sécurité des français et que
c'est une tarification nécessaire qu'on
a comme on n'a qu'une seule mère on
accusa le patrie il y à une surenchère
d'un peu comme ça sur les questions de
sécurité ce que vous êtes surpris ou
satisfait que françois hollande reprenne
une partie des idées des délits front
national sur messi encore une fois il ya
un certain nombre de propositions de bon
sens quand est faite par le président de
la république et c'est tant mieux
et aussi par le premier ministre mais
les déclarations d'intention les paroles
ne sont pas suffisantes il faut passer
maintenant aux actes il faut réformer la
politique pénale il faut l'avouer on dit
que c'est une victoire idéologique
évidemment écoutez nous avons dit oui
nous avons dit ce qui est évoquée
parfois aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
pendant des dizaines d'années sous les
insultes parfois en étant menacé de
procès et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
finalement qu'on est devenus des gens
tout à fait tout à fait extraordinaire
j'espère que les français vont se rendre
compte de la complicité de l'ensemble de
la classe politique dans ce dossier pas
voir ça tout de suite avec la loupe du
scan
jim fait avoue david rachline on va
reparler en plus des élections
régionales mardi soir vous étiez à
toulon pour assister au meeting de
marion maréchal-le pen qui est candidate
front national dans la région paca alors
vous parle il ya quelques secondes de ce
qu'est être français justement elle a
voulu énuméré un peu les critères qui
doivent selon elle respectait les
musulmans pour être considérés à ses
yeux comme français par exemple je cite
se plier aux moeurs et au mode de vie
que l' influence grecque romaine et
seize siècles de chrétienté ont façonné
elle a aussi critiqué ceux qui vivent en
djellaba
quel rapport avec les compétences du
conseil régional david rachline ouais on
a parfaitement le droit dans le cadre
d'un meeting politique de parler de ce
dont on a envie tout à l'heure vous
allez y compris dans les comptes dans le
cadre des grands prix -y compris de ce
qui intéresse les français
marc étienne blanc sable quelques
minutes avant que notre tête de liste
dans le var parler des compétences
régionales de l'économie du
développement économique et marion a
fait une analyse que général vous savez
pourquoi
parce que les français attendent des
solutions suite à ce qui s'est passé
dans notre pays et je crois que nous en
importons qu'elle en apporte elle aussi
un certain nombre donc alors ses propos
ils ont quand même pas plu à tout le
monde au sein de vue front national on
est entendu vallerand de saint-just
notamment qui est candidat front
national en ile de france
il a dit ces propos sont inutiles moi
j'essaye d'embrasser tous les êtres
humains qui habitent sur le sol de la
région que voudrait diriger
ça vous inspire un commentaire ça
m'inspire pas de commentaire particulier
si ce n'est que chacun est libre de
porter le message qu'il souhaite
nous ne sommes pas dans une secte au
front national il ya pas de lignes
verticales ouvert ce que je peux vous
dire en tout cas c'est que le front
national on considère l'ensemble des
français comme des français à part
entière mais il y a c'est pas parce
qu'on a dit ça comme préalable qu'il
faut éviter le débat sur l'avancée des
communautarismes et le recul de notre
république dans un certain nombre de cas
l'avancé de revendication
politico-religieuse qui essayent de
transgresser parfois la loi de la
république
on doit se poser de ces questions on
doit lutter pour davantage
d'assimilation on doit rappeler quelle
est l'identité de notre pays cette
identité nationale qui doit être partagé
en effet marion maréchal-le pen a raison
là dessus par l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes est respecté à minima par
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes il ya des
points de vue différents centres votre
pâte parti sur cette question mais
également sur la question du planning
familial marion maréchal-le pen annoncé
qu'elle supprimerait les subventions au
planning parce que je cite ça apporte
une approche banaliser l'avortement
marine le pen elle n'aide pas du tout
cas d'accord pardon elle dit j'estime
avoir des choses beaucoup plus
importantes à faire et elle ne prévoit
donc pas de supprimer les allocs
vous avez choisi votre camp vous david
rachline le principe est le suivant
chaque candidat s'adresse à aux
habitants de sa région et lui propose un
projet on n'est pas obligé de dupliquer
systématiquement le même projet à la
tension est au coude à les supprimer
il y a il y à un certain nombre de
situations spécifiques dans le
territoire qui verront des propositions
économiques en matière formation qui ne
seront pas les mêmes par exemple qui ne
seront pas les mêmes
en paca que dans la région mais alors
entraîné par conséquent chaque candidat
est libre de faire les propositions
qu'ils souhaitent
je ne crois pas à titre personnel que je
sois en effet la priorité absolue
mais chacun est libre et chacun chaque
position de chaque candidat doit être
respectée alors un autre élu proche du
fn a fait parler lui cette semaine il
s'agit de robert ménard il était présent
à toulon 6e mardi le maire de béziers a
proposé la création d'une garde
biterroise ans je cite encore sortes de
milices composées d'anciens policiers
d'anciens employeurs supplée à la police
municipale
mais le préfet après je vais vous savez
il ya des règles vous savez on est dans
un état de droit donc si le préfet si
l'état lui donne l'autorisation pour le
faire qu'ils le veulent entrer facture
il ya assez prononcée contre je sais ce
que j'allais vous dire le préfet il se
trouve que le préfet lui a écrit pour
lui dire qu' il n'était pas d'accord
avec cela donc il n'y aura pas de garde
biterroise il ya un état de droit la
république est une et indivisible la loi
est respectée le préfet a dit ce qu'il
avait quelle était la position de l'état
les choses sont claires il n'y aura pas
pas plus que cette garde maintenant et
ce n'est vite on pas le débat qu'est ce
qu'il a voulu faire robert ménard c'est
alerter les français sur la
problématique de la sécurité dans nos
communes
parce qu'à force de nous supprimer
des dotations tel qu'ils le font un
million et demi je voulais dit tout à
l'heure dans ma commune eh bien on fait
des investissements ont fait moins
d'investissements qu'avant on ne peut
plus avoir des effectifs suffisants en
termes de polices municipales on manque
de moyens le privé et on fera pas appel
au privé on essaiera d'augmenter les
moyens en tout cas dans nos villes de la
police municipale mais ça n'est pas
évident parce qu'on manque de soutien
financier et l'état là-dessus porte une
grave responsabilité
jamie une minute dernière question ne
l'avait pas vu depuis longtemps jean
marie le pen a fait son retour
médiatique cette semaine dans une
interview il a appelé à voter pour tous
les candidats front national y compris
florian philippot quand même son ennemi
juré des derniers mois c'est quoi c'est
là la hache de guerre est enterrée entre
20 et le pen et le front ou alors est-ce
que c'est un appel un peu nécessaire du
père fondateur dans l'est dans les
mouvements politiques il peut y avoir
des difficultés à surmonter
marine le pen avait dit un certain
nombre de désaccords avec jean marie le
pen elle n'a elle a osé le faire avec la
plus grande clarté parce qu'on ne devait
la clarté aux français maintenant
j'aimerais le pen est un homme
responsable et il sait bien que c'est
pour le front national qu'il faut
derrière le front national qu'il faut
être pour redresser ce pays savent où il
n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs parce
qu'avec lui manifestement il ya 30% des
français ça ouvre la porte à cette
analyse
ça vous voilà donc un nouveau
rapprochement entre jean marie le pen
mais je ne sais pas je ne crois pas en
tout cas juste en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que ceux qui veulent
redresser ces régions ceux qui veulent
porter une politique alternative aux
responsabilités ceux qui veulent sortir
des errances de la droite et de la
gauche au pouvoir depuis des dizaines
d'années doivent voter pour le front
national à ces élections régionales je
pense que c'est clair merci ce sera le
mot de la fin david rachline merci
d'avoir été l'invité de parlons à cela
vous devrez nos sorties de la semaine
prochaine n'oubliez pas de suivre la
soirée électorale soit chaîne
parlementaire dès 9h30 dimanche soir